[Music]
this morning on the dish a woman who's
turned farm-to-table meat production
into a thriving business Anya Fernald
has long been interested not just in
great food but where it comes from and
how it's grown and raised after working
in the food industry in Europe she
returned to her native California and
co-founded Bell Campo the company farms
nearly 50,000 acres of organic land
where animals are pasture fed and
humanely raised and that supplies a
chain of combination butcher shops and
restaurants across California along with
a brand new location that opened this
spring right here in New York and Anya
Fernald is with us good morning and
welcome to the dish thanks for having me
this looks amazing the colors the food
the smells what are we eating here well
starting out with our bone in New York
steak I had to lead with steak being a
beef rancher primarily so this is a
beautiful boning that's been grilled for
you guys as well as some of the sausages
that we make from our own pigs and we
have kielbasa and bratwurst and then we
just balance it with some vegetables I
have a green bean salad with bacon on it
again bacon from our farm and operation
and then we did some roasted carrots
pickled egg in beets and then did a
little sweet bit is a peach tart with
creme fraiche and this yummy this is a
Kapali daiquiri so my company also run
it here its operation in Belize so this
is an organic rum daiquiri for all this
so I know you spend time in Europe did
living and working in Europe change your
view on food 100% you know I grew up in
the low-fat 90's
right I moved to Europe when I started
working in dairies and all of a sudden I
was eating like a pound of John today
right and I got way healthier I leaned
out yeah my mood improved and I was
maybe this isn't the maybe the low-fat
program is not my program right and I
think a lot of people in the past couple
years when the us have kind of come
around to say well protein and fat if
it's the good clean stuff is actually
pretty good for us or a great fuel so I
started working in dairies and just that
health transformation for myself totally
change my perspective and really fuel
really what I'm doing today pretty some
people meat is on the way out looking at
this table that's clearly not the case
for you you've been called the carnivore
with a conscious so what
is what is the most important thing for
you to do right now
we farm regenerative Li which means that
we actually sequester carbon which is a
fancy way of saying that our beef is
good for the environment we are a net
positive player and how are you able to
do that it's by raising beef with a
natural diet so they're fed only grass
all of our animals are fed what they
evolved
99% of beef in the u.s. is fed corn
which makes it a lot fattier makes it
grow faster but it's not as healthy for
the animals or for the planet so
basically let's it's it's not as hard on
their system it's not as hard of the
system but also the feed that we're
raising it's perennial grasses so they
actually sequester carbon so on our farm
the grasses have 30 feet of roots under
them so you're talking about taking
carbon it's the same thing that happens
like in the rainforests right now
perennial system it takes carbon out so
the animals still do produce some
methane less than in quite often in fat
but it's actually a major part of my
platform and my story is you can feel
awesome about this for your health for
the animals welfare and then also for
the planet and that's a really powerful
statement with how much information
there is now about how bad it is for
carbon yeah so you have not just the
farm but you have two restaurants I mean
do you see the Bell combo method as
being sort of them the model of the
future we're looking to build Bell Campo
into a meat brand that Americans can
trust for their health and for the
environment so restaurants are a big
part of that platform we also are
selling through grocery now and we do
delivery only restaurants as well so
we're really building out the platform
and I opened here in New York we now
have six restaurants roping San Mateo
this fall that will be my seventh so the
restaurants are part of it but I want to
create a lot of different ways to get
clean meat I think people want clean
meat they want to feel good about it
meets a complicated decision yeah people
want to know it's okay to eat it you
don't want to feel guilty in that moment
what about having farms having
restaurants biggest difference between
those two and what you have to do
there's such different businesses and
it's been a long journey you know it's
we started the company in 2012 and gosh
the mistakes and the challenges but so
much learning it's been really exciting
to bring it together and the whole
reason to bring it together is just
traceability and security you know I can
tell you not the name of that
but I can trace it back to that cow that
I can write so that level of security so
learning those different businesses is
really worth it for what I can offer the
consumer is one more difficult than the
other
I'd say farming is the most challenging
business in our whole operation just
because there's so many things with the
environment and also we're breaking the
mold with how farming and ranching is
done in America so there's not like a
playbook that I can follow to do things
at the scale that we're doing and
farming regenerative lis not cheap to do
it that way it isn't our product is that
a premium absolutely I mean like many
things associated with wellness there's
a premium with that health product right
it's a different product with a
different slightly different price well
if you can have this meal with anyone
past or present who would it be
I've always had a crush on Elvis Presley
and I likes bacon so I'm gonna go for
[Laughter]
Elvis Presley in that have to pick bacon
bacon peanut butter and a lot of good
foods I know we thank you so much thanks
for having me and for more on Anya and
the dish head to our website at CBS this
morning calm